STAY TUNED.
BRIAN: WE WILL SEE.
AINSLEY: TEXAS COUNTIES
OVERWHELMED AS YOU KNOW BY AS
MANY AS 30,000 ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN JUST THE PAST FEW
WEEKS.
SUING THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
NOW OVER ITS HANDLING OF THE
BORDER CRISIS.
STEVE: THIS COMES AS PAN MAN PAN
OFFICIALS CAN’T HANDLE THIS
TELLING AXIOS, QUOTE, THE WHITE
HOUSE SEEMED CAUGHT OFF GUARD.
BRIAN: THEY SHOULDN’T HAVE BEEN
BECAUSE THEY GOT A WARNING MONTH
AGO.
IS ANYBODY WORKING THERE?
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR LARA TRUMP
JOINS US NOW TO REACT.
IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
PANAMA, WHO IS AN ALLY OF OURS,
WOULD HAVE TROUBLE GETTING
THROUGH TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> YEAH, WELL, IT SEEMS RATHER
PURPOSEFUL.
DOESN’T IT, BRIAN?
THAT THIS IS ALL HAPPENING.
WHAT AN EMBARRASSMENT.
THIS IS YET ANOTHER WORLD LEADER
WHO IS CALLING OUT THE COUNTRY,
CALLING OUT THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SAYING YOU GUYS
BETTER PAY ATTENTION TO THIS
BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT DOING YOUR
JOB.
REMEMBER, WHEN OUR BORDER CZAR
KAMALA HARRIS WENT DOWN TO
GUATEMALA AND THE GUATEMALAN
PRESIDENT EMBARRASSED HER BY
SAYING YOU GUYS SEND BAD
MESSAGING AND YOU ARE TELLING
PEOPLE TO COME UP THROUGH, YOU
KNOW, OUR COUNTRIES AND COME TO
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
SO, I MEAN, IT’S CRAZY THAT YOU
ARE RIGHT THAT PANAMA COULDN’T
WARN THE UNITED STATES BUT,
BRIAN, THEY KNOW IT’S HAPPENING
AND AT A CERTAIN POINT PEOPLE
HAVE TO ASK THEMSELVES, IS THIS
JUST PART OF THE DEMOCRAT PLAN?
AND I THINK WE HAVE TO KEEP
TALKING ABOUT THAT BECAUSE THIS
SORT OF THING CANNOT BE AN
ACCIDENT.
WHEN YOU DO NOT SECURE YOUR
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WHEN DO YOU NOT FOLLOW THE LAWS
OF THE LAND, WHICH JOE BIDEN IS
NOT DOING, I MEAN, IT’S GOT TO
BE PURPOSEFUL.
STEVE: LARA, THIS WEEK THEY WERE
BREAKING GROUND FOR THE BARACK
OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL LIBRARY.
ABC SAT DOWN WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA, AND HE
WAS ASKED ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON
ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER WITH THE
WIDE OPEN BORDERS, AND HE SAID,
IT’S UNSUSTAINABLE.
BUT THEY DID NOT RUN THAT
PARTICULAR CLIP ON TELEVISION.
IT WAS HIDDEN ON THE INTERNET.
WE DUG IT UP.
HERE’S THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE’RE A NATION STATE.
WE HAVE BORDERS.
THE IDEA THAT WE CAN JUST HAVE
OPEN BORDERS IS SOMETHING THAT,
I THINK, AS A PRACTICAL MATTER,
IS, IS UNSUSTAINABLE.
STEVE: AND, LARA, THAT’S THE
HEADLINE FROM THE INTERVIEW AND
THEY DIDN’T PLAY IT.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, AGAIN, THESE THINGS ARE
NOT ACCIDENTS.
THIS IS THE SAME MEDIA THAT --
THIS IS WHAT THEY DID THROUGHOUT
THE ENTIRETY OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
THROUGHOUT THE CAMPAIGN IN 2020.
CAMPAIGN QUITE FRANKLY IN 2016 I
MEAN IS LYING BY OMISSION.
AND IT DOESN’T TAKE A ROCKET
SCIENTIST, STEVE, TO FIGURE OUT
THAT IF YOU DO NOT HAVE BORDERS,
YOU DON’T HAVE A COUNTRY.
IF YOU CAN’T PREVENT PEOPLE FROM
JUST FREE FLOWING INTO YOUR
COUNTRY, THEN THE SOVEREIGNTY OF
YOUR COUNTRY IS TOTALLY GONE.
BUT I MEAN, I GUESS THE GOAL IS
TO, YOU KNOW, PROP UP THE
DEMOCRATS AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEIR TALKING POINTS ARE OUT
THERE AND THEY DON’T WANT PEOPLE
TO HEAR THAT.
BARACK OBAMA IS RIGHT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE BORDERS AND WE
HAVE TO ENFORCE THE LAWS AT OUR
BORDERS.
AND, UNFORTUNATELY, IT IS NOT
BEING DONE RIGHT NOW.
IT IS INCREDIBLY DETRIMENTAL TO
THE UNITED STATES.
BRIAN: THE A.P. CALLED, THEY
WANT CONFIRMATION.
YOU SAID BARACK OBAMA WAS RIGHT,
RIGHT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> MAYBE THE ONE TIME THAT I’M
GOING TO AGREE WITH HIM, YES.